I think some of the things that I don't
even need to be aware of are just vile
and disgusting Selena Gomez is not here
for any sort of online bullying the
actress calls out her fans one day after
Haley Bieber's appearance on call her
daddy where the model opened up about
being a frequent Target well I think
there's like a certain like almost like
numbness that you get where you're just
like
you just know what's going to happen it
still happens to this day you just reach
a point where you're just like you have
to just like ignore it and be like okay
Selena expressed her feelings during a
Tick-Tock live not fair no one ever
should be spoken to in the manner that
I've seen the bullying stems from Selena
and Haley's history with Justin Bieber
Selena of course dated Justin for years
before they ultimately split Justin
moved on with Haley and they tied the
knot in 2018. there are people that hate
you for who your husband dated back in
his past a lot of the hate and the
perpetuation comes from like oh you
stole him
and I guess maybe that just comes from
like the fact that they wished that like
he had ended up with someone else and
that's fine like you can wish that all
you want but that's just not the case
Haley also added she doesn't blame
Selena or thinks she's obligated to
speak up to tell her fans to stop I have
no expectation I would never expect
someone to do that for me like she
doesn't owe me anything
I don't owe neither of us owe anybody
anything except like respect but cell
she's not having it and made it clear
she's not cool with any sort of hate
being flung Haley's way she even reminds
fans about the true meaning behind her
rare Beauty line all I have to say is
it's incredibly ironic that I would
release something that is all about kind
words
because that's exactly what I want
that's it
if you support rare I cannot thank you
enough that know that you are also
representing
what it means and that is
words matter
truly matter
so
it ain't coming from me
and I just want all of you to know that
I hope that you understand that this is
much bigger than anything else I'm
constantly somebody that likes to grow
and feel like all right what could I be
better at what could I do better at
where where could my confidence be
stronger plus this only just confirms
what Haley said there's nothing but good
vibes between them it's all respect it's
all love that's also why I feel like
well if everybody on our side knows
what happened and we're good and we
could walk away from it with Clarity and
respect then like
right that's fine
[Music]